Okay, you ready?
♪
♪ Living in our high life ♪
♪ We're up on the high life ♪
The idea of the scene
should be that they're…
even though they're not
making it up as they go along,
it should feel like
a live performance
- Yeah.
- in a little pub in Dublin.
I just love the idea
of little riffs that, like, felt like,
"Okay, I can see a
15-year-old kid doing that."
-Yeah, yeah.
- So, it's nothing too complex.
So I just love that.
(John singing with drum beat)
It's gotta be a marriage of…
of creativity between a kid
who's on GarageBand
and who has beats,
with a girl who knows three chords.
Her contribution, guitar-wise,
has to be really simple.
And the audience have to go,
"I totally buy that."
I think there's notes that can
kind of hang through the chorus.
Like…
♪
♪ I'm not living in your life ♪
♪ You're not living in mine ♪
- You're saying keep four on the floor.
- Yeah.
- Is there a way to do that?
- ♪ Living the high life ♪
♪ I'm a b*tch…
but I'm your b*tch ♪
"And…
and I'm all you've got."
And she's kind of singing it
to the audience,
but she's also straining to speak to him,
and he's coming back to her.
Now he can't, you know -
and won't - sing,
so it would be kind of absurd,
in this movie,
if suddenly he was like…
Ed Sheeran or something, or singing out.
Being the kid he is,
living in the flats
and hanging out
with the guys doing drill,
he might do a little rap.
So, I've been trying to write
from the point of view
of a 14-year-old Dublin boy.
- Well, you once were.
- And this is my best effort.
This isn't my dumbing down
to try and get into his head.
This is the best rap I can do.
♪ Woman ♪
♪ Guess we're cut from the same cloth ♪
♪ Fourteen years on the same block ♪
♪ Nine long months in your belly ♪
♪ Down to the coom,
I still wasn't ready.
♪ Three days late,
I arrive at the party ♪
♪ Smile on my face,
You're welcome, me hearty ♪
Give me the bit just before that.
Um, so it would be…
♪ Girl, we're cut from the same cloth ♪
♪ Everything you feel,
I feel the same loss ♪
♪ I see your eyes in the mirror ♪
♪ Saint, angel, devil, sinner ♪
Then I don't have anything else.
(John singing)
♪ Still here in the high life ♪
Bang! And she's like,
"F*ckin' hell!"
You know, so if he's saying,
"What I've realized at the end of all this
is actually we're dead similar."
- It's actually weirdly moving.
- Yes.
- Do you know what I mean?
- I actually think it can be.
For a second you think it's funny,
and then it, like, hits you
with a killer emotional line.
♪ We're living the high life ♪
♪ Living in our high life ♪
♪ We're up on the high life ♪
♪ And it's a fine night to feel alive ♪
♪ We're living the high life ♪
(audience clapping along with music)